and everyone's talking about 2020. it's
almost become one of these buzzwords but
in terms of technology and ftth what
about beyond 2020
well you're asking the right question
we are currently thinking that if the
investment horizon is between
10 15 20 years we really need to look at
the needs for connectivity speed and
quality beyond 2020.
at this conference many people heard the
commissioner saying that his vision for
the future is the gigabit society
in which
high-speed symmetrical
access to internet and low latency are
going to be very important
so
at the moment we know what companies
would like to build
what we do not have a very good vision
for is what people will need there is
obviously a limitation of predicting the
future predicting the future is very
difficult
but one good answer is that we will need
more we will need more speed we need
better quality
how do we build it into a good robust
vision that people will
federate around in order to build
networks yes i mean how do we actually
get there between now and then
you may have heard that there are three
elements
at the european level which we can put
together to support that movement and
that dynamics there's policy a certain
vision tracing direction making sure
that people from the public sector from
the private sector are walking in the
same direction
there is a regulatory framework which is
currently coming for a review
and there is financing there is a lot of
financing at the moment with the juncker
plan currently operational
we are also reviewing the regulatory
framework for the digital sector in the
dsm but also in the telecom sector as
such which will touch specifically the
future investment in broadband and
investment is actually a key word in our
reflection how to define the regulatory
framework
it is extremely important that nothing
in this framework
is
a
barrier to investment or a disincentive
to investment whether it is for big
companies for alternative operators or
for community-based local projects we
want all of these people
to really start digging and invest
so that we can have networks fit for the
21st century now talking about networks
we are now getting a bit of an
infrastructure at least in fdth how will
that platform integrate with all these
new sexy things we keep hearing about
internet of things cloudification 5g how
will that all mesh in do you think
digital single market is going to be
based on
a great increase of communication
between people between machines between
objects
therefore connectivity will be a key
question
to that new
market to that new understanding of the
market
so
it is a condition it is a necessary
condition although may not necessarily
sufficient condition
to digital single market being a success
if you take 5g
all engineers say that 5g is not going
to happen
unless there's fiber in the ground very
close
to any device you might be using on the
go
so we are not talking kilometers we're
talking 100 perhaps 200 meters
to where the actual cable needs to be
now these cables are going to be perhaps
not entirely fiber but definitely
predominantly fiber
so fiber is a word we're going to hear a
lot in the context of these new
initiatives cloudification 5g or i think
or internet of things whatever happens
it's going to be very exciting indeed
thank you for sharing that with us today
thank you